GETTING OUR ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON BUDGET INFORMATIONAL HEARING
WE ARE HEARING. TWO ITEMS S. B. --
EIGHT FOUR NINE AND S. B..
EIGHT FIVE SIX WITH THAT WE WILL
BEGIN WITH MISS COSTA.
S. B..
EIGHT FOUR NINE GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR ANY COSTS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
I HAD THIS BILL WILL ACTUALLY
RELATE TO THE NEXT BILL SO I
YOU'LL A PARDON YOU MIGHT GO A
LITTLE BIT BACK AND FORTH I'M I
WOULD KNOW THAT THIS BILL
CONTAINS SOME OF THE PROVISIONS
RELATED TO PROPOSITION.
FIFTY SIX ARM I'D ALSO NOTE THAT
THE BUDGET ACT A ALLOCATED ONE
POINT TWO FOUR BILLION IN
PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX FUNDS.
CONTAINED WITHIN THIS PROVISION --
APART MEET WITH IN THIS BILL IS
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION FOR
THE LOAN ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
WHICH WILL BE AVAILABLE UNTIL
JUNE THIRTIETH.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AT THE TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION ONE
HUNDRED NINETY MILLION IS
AVAILABLE FOR RECENT GRADUATE
PHYSICIANS AND THIRTY MILLION
FOR RECENT GRADUATE DENTISTS
OTHER REMAINING PROVISIONS --
OF THE FIFTY SIX A DEAL WILL BE
IN THE NEXT BILL BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE.
BUT THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU ANY COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE ANY --
ANYBODY IN SUPPORT WANNA COME
FORWARD.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC A SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MITCHELL POCKET WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
OUT WE ARE PLEASED WITH THE
INVESTMENT --
IN THIS BILL FOR PHYSICIAN LOAN
REPAYMENT --
AS YOU MAY KNOW OF POSITIONS --
CAN GRADUATE WITH SIGNIFICANT
THAT -- ONCE
THEY FINISH MEDICAL SCHOOL WE
BELIEVE THIS WOULD A GO A LONG
WAY IN.
ADDRESSING THAT ISSUE ALONG WITH.
CARE FOR MEDI CAL BENEFICIARIES
SO WE ARE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
NEXT.
MARY VALDEZ OF HEALTHAXIS
CALIFORNIA HEALTHAXIS IS ONE OF
THE SPONSORS HELP RIGHT AYE.
AND HELP PASS PROP FIFTY SIX
PLAN ALTHOUGH WE'VE BEEN
HISTORICALLY SUPPORTIVE OF
INCREASES IN MEDICARE PROVIDER
PAYMENTS I'M WE ARE DEEPLY
DISAPPOINTED THAT UNALLOCATED
PROP FIFTY SIX FUNDS.
DID NOT GO TOWARDS MORE COVERAGE
EXPANSIONS OR TO HELP FIX
POLICIES LIKE THE SENIOR PENALTY
AND MEDI CAL AND HOPE THAT IN
THE FUTURE --
THESE FUNDS ARE ALSO CONSIDERED
FOR COVERAGE EXPANSIONS AND THE
MEDI CAL PROGRAM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND NAME THEM AND THE
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
ANYBODY OPPOSED.
OKAY SEEING NONE.
ARE WE WILL MOVE ON TO S. B..
EIGHT FIVE SIX THANK YOU THIS IS
THE BUDGET BILL JUNIOR AS A
PREVIOUSLY TESTIFIED IT WILL
CONTAIN PROVISIONS BOTH RELATED
TO PROP FIFTY SIX AS WELL AS THE
CAP AND TRADE AGREEMENTS.
ON SPECIFICALLY WITH THEM
PROPOSITION.
FIFTY SIX IT --
APPROPRIATES --
IN THE BUDGET ACT WE
APPROPRIATED ONE POINT TWO FOUR
BILLION FOR PROP FIFTY SIX OF
WHICH TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN
POINT SEVEN MILLION WHAT'S FOR
GROWTH IN THE MEDI CAL PROGRAM
AS COMPARED TO THE TWENTY
SIXTEEN BUDGET ACT. SEVEN
BILLION FOR A 50% RATE INCREASE
FOR PEDIATRIC A DAY HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES AND WE SET ASIDE THE
ONE POINT OH TWO BILLION AND SO
ON THOSE DOLLARS ARE CONTAINED
WITHIN THIS PARTICULAR BELL.
INCLUDES --
A NUMBER OF INVESTMENTS FOR
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS RATE
INCREASES IN THE LOAN ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM WHICH I TESTIFIED TO IN
THE PREVIOUS BILL.
ADDITION IS PART OF ON THIS BILL
WE THE BUDGET ACT THAT ARE
INCLUDED AND LASTLY WE DO HAVE
PROVISIONS RELATED TO CAP AND
TRADE --
NOTABLY THE CAP AND TRADE
PROVISIONS INCLUDE ONE POINT
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS AYE IN
TOTAL EXPENDITURES THAT SLIGHTLY
HIGHER THAN OUR MAY REVISED
PROPOSAL AT THE TIME OF
PUBLICATION MAY REVISE WE DIDN'T
HAVE THE MAY AUCTION --
REVENUE RESULTS IN SAID THIS
PACKAGE ACCOUNTS WITHOUT AND
ALSO INCLUDES A SLIGHT INCREASE
IN OUR FORECAST.
IT ALSO INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS AYE
AND YOU'RE A FUNDING FOR AB SIX
SEVENTEEN FOR COMMUNITY AIR
PROTECTION AS WELL AS TO TWENTY
MILLION AND YOU GIRAFFE AND
FIFTY MILLION TOTAL FUNDS FOR
LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS TO IMPLEMENT.
SIX SEVENTEEN AS WELL THE
HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION FOR OUR
HEALTHY RESILIENT FORCE PROPOSAL.
AS WELL AS TWENTY FIVE MILLION
FOR LOCAL FIRE RESPONSE WITH
THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
LAKE MISCAST ANY.
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MISTER
OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SOUGHT A
QUESTION ABOUT THE CAP AND TRADE
EXPENDITURE PLAN.
CAN YOU GO THROUGH WITH US THE
RATIONALE THAT YOU USED IN
ALLOCATING MONEY TO DIFFERENT BY
PROGRAMS FROM CAPITA RATE.
SURE I'M I THINK GENERALLY
YOU'LL SEE WHEN WE DO DISPLAYS
WE LOOK AT AND THE ENACTING
LEGISLATION HAD SEVERAL
DIFFERENT CATEGORIES LISTED FOR
CAP AND TRADE EXPENDITURES IN
THOSE THINGS INCLUDE THINGS LIKE
AIR TOXIC AND CLIMATE AIR
POLLUTANTS.
AS WELL AS RESEARCH IS THAT WE
LOOK AT THOSE CATEGORIES WHEN WE
PUT TOGETHER THIS EXPENDITURE
PLAN OF COURSE IT'S PART OF A
NEGOTIATED AGREEMENT WITH
LEGISLATIVE LEADERSHIP AND SO
THERE'S ALWAYS SOME COMPROMISES
WHILE SPARS SCENE OF DOLLAR
AMOUNTS WITHIN THOSE.
BROAD CATEGORIES BUT THESE ARE
SUPPOSED TO USE FOR GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION ZACHAREK
[inaudible]
THAT'S CORRECT.
SO WHEN WHEN I LOOK AT SPENDING
TAXPAYER MONEY FOR GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION.
I THINK THAT TO BE GOOD STEWARDS
OF THAT MONEY WE NEED TO LOOK AT
THE EFFICIENCY OF OUR SPENDING
AND IN THIS CASE EFFICIENCIES
REALLY EASY TO CALCULATE BECAUSE
YOU JUST TAKE A TOTAL COST OF A
PROGRAM.
IN DOLLARS YOU DIVIDE BY THE
NUMBER OF TONS OF CARBON IT
REDUCES AND YOU GET THE PRICE
PER TONNE --
THAT ACOSTA REDUCE THAT AND I
WAS JUST STRUCK LOOKING AT THE
EXPENDITURE PLANET THE WIDE
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
EFFICIENCIES BECAUSE WE GOT SOME
PROGRAMS WERE FUNDING THAT ARE
VERY EFFICIENT I MEAN I HEALTHY
FOREST A DAIRY DIE JESTERS --
ORGANIC RECYCLING ALL OF THOSE
ARE UNDER TEN DOLLARS PER TON OF
CARBON REDUCED BUT THEN WE GOT
THINGS LIKE THE CLEAN VEHICLE
REBATE PROGRAM WHICH IS FORTY
SIX DOLLARS PER TON THAT'S FOUR
TIMES LESS EFFICIENT.
AND THEN --
THE CLEAN TRUCK AND BUS VOUCHER
INCENTIVE PROGRAM WHICH IS OVER
FORTY AND FIFTY DOLLARS PER TON
WHICH IS OVER TEN TIMES LESS
WHAT NO FORTY FORTY TIMES LESS
EFFICIENT SO.
THAT JUST STRUCK ME THAT THE
VARIETY OF EFFICIENCIES THERE
WHY NOT JUST TAKE THE MONEY I
MEAN IF IF THE GOAL IS TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GASES WITH THIS MONEY.
AND THAT'S WERE CHARGED WITH
DOING WHY NOT JUST ALLOCATE THEM
TO THE MOST EFFICIENT USES USERS
Y. WHILE THE OTHER THING I THINK
THAT WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT OR
PUTTING IT TOGETHER EXPENDITURE
PLAN IS CURRENT EVENTS AND SO
CLEARLY WE HAVE A PRETTY
SUBSTANTIAL INVESTMENT IN
HEALTHY FORCE.
THIS YEAR GIVEN WHAT HAPPENS ON
RECENTLY ON PROBABLY --
HIGHER THAN WE HAVE IN PAST YEAR
HE IS ONE LENDS TO LOOK THROUGH
THE ALSO THINK WE NEED TO LOOK
AT MORE RECENT EVENTS TO SEE IF
THERE ARE INVESTMENTS THAT WE
SHOULD BE MADE.
ON AN FORCES CERTAINLY A GREAT
EXAMPLE OF THAT NIGHT FEEL GET
NO ARGUMENT FROM ME BERMAN
BECAUSE KURT WITH EVENTS WITH
NOTWITHSTANDING.
HEALTHY FORESTS ARE ONE OF MOST
EFFICIENT USES OF GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUNDS IN TERMS OF
DOLLARS SPENT PER TONS OF CARBON
REDUCED I JUST WONDERED WHY.
WE'RE SPENDING ALL OF THIS
TAXPAYER MONEY ON YOU KNOW VERY
INEFFICIENT USES.
WHEN WE LOOK TO YOU THROUGH THE
LINES OF GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION BUT DOC I MEAN THAT'S
A RHETORICAL QUESTION I GUESS
IT'S IT'S ONE OF THE BIG
CONCERNS I HAVE THOUGH?
AND I WOULD HOPE THAT IN FUTURE
YEARS WE PAY MORE ATTENTION TO
THAT EFFICIENCY WHEN WE ALLOCATE
THIS MONEY BACK MISTER WHO OUGHT
TO CRACK ANSWERED THE RHETORICAL
QUESTION I THINK WE END UP --
SPENDING THOSE CATEGORIES BASED
ON AREAS WHERE THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT NEEDS AND
IMPROVEMENTS NEEDED. FOR THAT SO
FOR EXAMPLE IN THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR
TRANSPORTATION ACCOUNTS FOR
ABOUT.
40% OF GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
SO IF WE ONLY WERE TO FOCUS ON
DIE JESTERS OR FOREST'S WE WENT
TOUCH.
ANY OF THE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS IN THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR I THINK YOUR YOUR POINT
ON NOW WAS TENURE CARD
EFFICIENCIES I THINK IS YOU KNOW
WELL.
WELL STATED AND I THINK THAT
THIS IS --
THESE ARE PROGRAMS THAT WE
CONTINUE TO TRY TO FIND THE MOST
EFFICIENT WAY TO REDUCE OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS IS NOT THE MOST
EFFICIENT WAY WOULD JUST SIMPLY
BE. TO TELL PEOPLE NOT TO DO
SOMETHING AND I THINK THAT'S NOT
ALWAYS THE MUST PRACTICAL WAY OF
ACHIEVING THAT SO I THINK THAT
WE DO.
ARM HOW THESE PROGRAMS TIME TO
IMPLEMENT AND AT TIMES --
FOR THEY GET TO BE --
MODIFY THE COMPLETE AND CONTINUE
TO BE APPROVED THAT --
OBVIOUSLY THE MORE IMPROVEMENT
THAT WE HAVE IN REDUCING
GREENHOUSE GASES.
THEN IT IT BECOMES HARDER AND
HARDER TO MOVE INTOAREAS THAT
WE HAVEN'T MADE AS MUCH PROGRESS
I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY YOU DO SEE.
OF A MENU OF OPTIONS FOR EXAMPLE
I DON'T KNOW THAT WE COULD PUT A
BILLION DOLLARS INTO THE DAIRY
TIE JESTERS AND WHILE THEY ARE
EFFICIENT ON THEY HAVE.
A DIFFERENT LEVELS OF
EFFICIENCIES DEPENDING ON THE
SIZE OF THE FARMS AND WHERE THEY
ARE PLACED SO AGAIN --
I THINK YOUR POINT IS POINT IS
WELL TAKEN IT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE CAN TO CONTINUE --
TO DELVE INTO AT THE COMMITTEE
LEVEL BUT LIKE AND AGAIN I THINK
THAT'S MISTER CHAIR NOTHING ON
THAT WOULD BE CAREFUL WITH THAT
SPECIAL THE DIGEST HERS I THE
MOST ADJUSTERS IN.
CALIFORNIA MY DISTRICT.
BECAUSE MONEY HAS VERY LOW RATES
AND THINK ABOUT SOME THINGS
WE'VE DONE FOR OUR DAIRY HERDS --
FARR'S FEW YEARS AGO AT ABOUT XP
THOUGH LOIS AND ABOUT IT RATE IN
THE NATION.
BUT WE DON'T DRIVE OUR DEAREST
OF CALIFORNIA.
IN THE GARDEN MILK PRODUCTS FROM
ELSEWHERE THAT IS A REAL ISSUE
THE THREAT WITH THAT.
AND THEN ALSO YOU CAN SEE V. RP
[inaudible] FOR LONGTIME.
THE MONEY WENT BACK TO RICH
FOLKS FOLKS THAT.
REALLY DIDN'T NEED THAT MUCH
HELP AND IS GHOSTLY HOV LANE SO
I MEAN RIGHT NOW YOU BY --
HYBRID AREA IN THE V. DRIVE THE
CAR PULLING.
H. O. V. LANES WERE MADE FOR
HIGH UP IN THE VEHICLES.
AND THE TERM HOV BUT NOW FOLKS
ARE DRIVING IT TO COMMUTE TO
WORK BASICALLY SO IF YOU CAN
AFFORD MTV.
NICOLA CARPOOLING IN THE
MEANTIME VEHICLES THAT.
ARE GAS GUZZLERS THAT ADMIT YOU
KNOW [inaudible]
A WE HAVE GAS EMISSIONS STUCK IN
PLANES TWO THREE AND FOUR
PUTTING UP THE WORLD SO IT'S
KIND OF OUR BALANCE THESE DAYS
LOOK AT A CAR PULLING.
MODEST SINGLE VEHICLES DRIVING
THROUGH THEIR SO I MEAN
SOMETIMES I THINK WE GOT OUR
PRIORITIES WRONG AND I DO AGREE
WE NEED WHAT'S THE BIGGEST BANG
FOR THE BUCK.
AND FOR NOT GETTING THAN SOME
THESE AREAS.
THANK YOU LAW ALL POINTS WELL
TAKEN.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
NOT SEEING ANYBODY IN SUPPORT OF
S. B..
EIGHT FIVE SIX GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LARA KNOW AND HE CHECK
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA FRESH
FRUIT ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
CONGENERS GROWERS ASSOCIATION --
CAT WESTERN I PROCESSORS
ASSOCIATION AND CALIFORNIA DERES
INK IN SUPPORT OF THE FUNDING
FOR AND THE DAIRY DIE JESTERS
METHANE REDUCTION AND THE
FUNDING FOR IT THE ACT DIESEL.
EQUIPMENT AND TRACTOR
REPLACEMENT AND ALSO FOR THE
FOOD PROCESSOR LANGUAGE THANK
YOU.
THIS IS MY YELLOW WITH
CALIFORNIA RELIEF OF THIS
MORNING WE DISTRIBUTE JUST
LETTER TO EVERY OTHER
LEGISLATIVE OFFICE --
SIGNED BY FORTY FIVE NATURAL
RESOURCES AND URBAN FORESTRY
NONPROFITS IN SUPPORT OF THE GDR
OF EXPENDITURE PLAN --
WELL THERE WERE VERY FEW DOLLARS
AVAILABLE FOR INVESTMENT IN
NATURAL RESOURCES THIS YEAR.
THOSE ALLOCATIONS MADE --
THROUGH DID YOU ARE FLYING
THROUGH THE EXISTING PARTY
NATURAL RESOURCES PROGRAMS.
THAT ARE SEQUESTERING CARBON
HELPING THE STATE ADOPT TO
CLIMATE CHANGE AND BUILDING --
COMMUNITY OF RESILIENCY AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR THE UMPS
SUPPORT IN LEADERSHIP AND WE
SUPPORT THE JARRETT EXPENDITURE
PLAN.
THINKING.
GOOD MORNING MADDIE DUNLAP ON
BEHALF OF THE AG ENERGY
CONSUMERS ASSOCIATION AND THE
CALIFORNIA POULTRY FEDERATION IN
SUPPORT OF THE AYE DIESEL ENGINE
REPLACEMENT MONEY.
THE DAIRY METHANE REDUCTION
FUNDING AND THE FOOD PROCESSOR
INVESTMENT FUNDING AS WELL THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING NO KRAMERS OF
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
THE AGRICULTURAL DIESEL
EQUIPMENT REPLACEMENT FUNDING
THE AT DAIRY METHANE REDUCTION
FUNDING AND THE FOOD PROCESSOR
AG EFFICIENT AND ENERGY
EFFICIENCY FUNDING THANK YOU.
WELL I MEAN ON A WITHOUT OF ON
CALIFORNIA HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE APPLICATIONS
PROVIDED.
OFFER THE WETLANDS PROGRAM AND
YOUR F. AND ALSO HELPS WILL
STICK YOU.
RENDON TOOK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICERS OF ALL THIRTY
FIVE LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS OUT WE
APPRECIATE THE INCREASED AMOUNTS
FOR AB SIX SEVENTEEN INCENTIVES
AND WERE SUPPORTIVE OF THAT.
WERE PARTICULARLY SUPPORTIVE AND
GRATEFUL FOR THE ON AB SIX
SEVENTEEN IMPLEMENTATION FOR AIR
DISTRICTS ARE AT WITH AND THE
RECOGNITION THAT COMES WITH THAT.
ON THE NEED FOR A ADEQUATE.
A PROMISE OF THE B. SIX
SEVENTEENTHS WE APPRECIATE THAT
A COUPLE MORE ITEMS IS JUST THAT
WOULD SMOKE FUNDING A WE
APPRECIATE THAT AS WELL.
AND OUT LAST THE FUNDING FOR OUR
AIR QUALITY MONITORING FOR
PRESCRIBED FIRES AND SO WE THANK
YOU FOR THAT AS WELL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
TOM EDISON BAY AREA HERE QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT AT ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE MISTER
TO A SURE MEMBERS CHECK OF LOS
THE SOUTH COAST AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT.
IT'S LIKE THEY'RE ALSO ECHO THE
OTHER DISTRICTS AND SAY.
THANK YOU FOR ALL THE WORK ON
BEHALF IDEA MEMBERS AND STAFF
AND EVERYONE HAS PUT INTO THIS.
BUDGET BUILDS IT'S BEEN A LOT OF
HOURS LOT ENERGY TO THINK.
MICHELLE BAKA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
PINKY TO THE COMMITTEE AND
RESTORATION FOR WORK ON THIS
ISSUE.
MORE PLEASED TO SEE A THAT THE
IDEALIST LAST YEAR CONTINUES TO
BE HONORED I IN THIS BUDGET --
WE ALSO --
WHAT JUST WANNA AND --
TO THE ADMINISTRATION --
FOR BED ADDITIONAL.
UP PREVENTIVE CODES THAT ARE
GOING TO BE GOING IN --
IN ADDITION TO THE INCREASES --
TO AT THE EXISTING CODES WE
THINK AND THAT THIS WILL ALSO GO
A LONG WAY TO ENCOURAGING
PROVIDER --
PARTICIPATION AND MEDI CAL AND
AMP AND IN TURN IMPROVE ACCESS
TO BENEFICIARIES THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS TRICIA GERINGER WITH
AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EXPENDITURE PLAN PARTICULARLY
THE I'M DIESEL ENGINE
REPLACEMENTS ON FARMS THAT THE
DURING THE NOR METHANE OUR
PRODUCTIONS FUNDS AND ALSO THE
FOOD PROCESSING.
FUNDING ACT TO REDUCE DAY STORY
SOURCE EMISSIONS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
I GOOD MORNING BRENT APARTMENTS
FUNDS ARE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DENTAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF
THE ALLOCATION OF THE PROP.
FIFTY SIX I'M SPENDING ONE OF
THINKING THAT CHAIR OUT AND
WE'RE FOR WORKING WITH --
THE SENATE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THIS
ALLOCATION BUT AGREE WITH THE
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION THAT THE
DEAL THAT WAS FOUND THIS YEAR IT
REALLY DOES FOR FILLED THAT DEAL
THAT YOU PUSHED FOR LAST YEAR
WITH THE GOVERNOR AND AND WE'RE
VERY EXCITED TO SEE THE
ADDITIONAL SPENDING AS WELL AS
THE LOAN.
REPAYMENT AND I WOULD BE REMISS
IF.
THE LAST ISSUE THAT YOU HEARD
INCLUDING THE HEALTH PLANS HIM
MATTEO AND DENTAL MEDICAL
INTEGRATION PILOT PROJECT WERE
VERY EXCITED. TO SEE THAT AND TO
TEST A NEW MODEL OF LATIN DENTAL
MANAGED CARE AND INTEGRATION
THANK YOU.
STEVE COONEY ON BEHALF OF
WESTERN DENTAL --
I'D JUST SAY THANKS IT WAS WORTH
THE WAIT --
AND AND WE PARTICULARLY
APPRECIATE THE EFFORT TO MAKE --
THESE --
IMPROVEMENTS NOT ONLY ADEQUATE
BUT BUT RELIABLE THANK YOU.
ROCKY RUSHING FOR COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR WHILE CCA SUPPORTS THE
GT R. F. COMPROMISE WE HOPE NEXT
YEAR'S BUDGET WILL SHOW.
GREATER INVESTMENT IN PROGRAMS
THAT IMPROVE THE LIVES OF THOSE
LIVING IN LOW INCOME AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
I'M SPEAKING SPECIFICALLY OF
URBAN FORESTRY AND URBAN GREEN.
TRANSFER AT TRANSFORMING
COMMUNITIES.
AND OUT CLEAN BUSES TRUCKS AND
PORTS [inaudible] TO MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE WE APPRECIATE THE
FUNDING INCLUDED FOR CAL
RECYCLES GRANT PROGRAMS OTHER
REALISTICALLY THE DEMAND IS FAR
GREATER.
AND SO WE HOPE TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE TO IDENTIFY
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING MECHANISMS
TO RECYCLE THE MATERIAL WE'VE
ALREADY BEEN COLLECTING AS WELL
AS DEVELOP NEW COMPOSTING
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THINKING.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN VARIOUS
TERESA CHO COMEY HALF OF FIRST
ELEMENT FUEL --
WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
THAT WE SEE YOU FOR THE AB ONE
EIGHTEEN PROGRAM I'M AN ACRONYM
THAT IS NOT WORTH ARE REPEATING.
OUT WE DO HOWEVER WORRY THAT
THAT AMOUNT OF MONEY IS NOT
GOING TO BE SUFFICIENT ENOUGH TO
YOU ARE PROVIDE THE FEELING
INFRASTRUCTURE.
NECESSARY FOR THE ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES THAT WE HOPE TO ACHIEVE
SOON I WOULD POINT OUT ALSO SOME
CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE WITH THE
ARE PROVISIONS STRIKINGLY.
TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR YOUR
ALLOCATION FOR HYDROGEN FUELING
INFRASTRUCTURE IT'S KIND OF
LEAVING UPS WITHOUT MORE
QUESTIONS THAN ASSURANCES AND
SOMETHING I HOPE THAT WE CAN
COVER IN A DISCUSSION SAME THANK
YOU.
I'M MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE KEVIN TO DRIVE A
REPRESENTING MAXIM HEALTHCARE.
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEES
FUNDING RATING [inaudible]
HEALTH CARE THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
USING THE PROP FIFTY SIX FUNDING
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MERCENARY VALDEZ OF HEALTH
ACCESS CALIFORNIA HEALTH ACCESS
HELPED DRAFT PROP FIFTY SIX AND
ACTIVELY HAVE HELPED BYPASS THE
MEASURE.
AND WHILE WE'VE BEEN
HISTORICALLY SUPPORTIVE OF
INCREASES AND PROVIDER RATES
WERE DEEPLY DISAPPOINTED TO SEE
THAT THIS YEAR THERE WAS NO --
MONEY IN UNALLOCATED PROP FIFTY
SIX FUNDS USED TOWARDS COVERAGE
EXPANSIONS OR ENDING POLICIES
LIKE THE SENIOR PENALTY WHERE
OUR LOW INCOME SENIORS WHO
QUALIFIED FOR MEDI CAL.
ARE ACTUALLY I STILL PAYING A
SHARE OF COST AND HAVE FURTHER
BARRIERS IN ACCESSING THEIR MEDI
CAL BENEFITS AND WE ALSO HOPE TO
SEE NEXT YEAR --
INVESTMENTS AND COVER THE
COVERAGE EXPANSIONS LIKE HEALTH
FOR ALL TO HELP US GET TO
UNIVERSAL COVERAGE THANK YOU.
CHRISTOPHER EARLY ON ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT
POLICY CENTER ARE ECHOING SOME
OF THE COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE
FROM HEALTHAXIS DISAPPOINTED TO
NOT SEE INVESTMENTS AND HEALTH
PROBLEM MADE THIS YEAR BUT LOOK
FORWARD TO NEXT YEAR --
AND CONTINUING THE PUSH THANK
YOU.
GEN POLY AT LAWRENCE BERKELEY
LAB APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT FOR
CLIMATE AND CLEAN ENERGY
RESEARCH.
THANK YOU THINK MISTER BLUE
MEDICAL.
UGH DOT QUESTION IF FOR THAT'S
ALRIGHT WITH YOU MISTER CHAIR I
WANT TO FOLLOW UP ON A MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC WHO BROUGHT UP THE A
ISSUE REGARDING HYDROGEN.
FUEL STATIONS AND THE
ELIMINATION OF WHAT WAS A TWENTY
MILLION DOLLAR MINIMUM THAT WAS --
STATUTORILY I THINK AND IN IT IN
PLACE AND THAT'S DISAPPEAR THEM
WHEN OUT OF A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
FOUR MILLION DOLLAR ALLOCATION
IN THE CURRENT PLAN BUT IT'S NOT.
DIVIDED IN ANYWAY AS IF I
UNDERSTAND CORRECTLY.
ALRIGHT SO MENTAL ME DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE --
EXISTING LAW.
WHICH WILL STAY IN PLACE --
ALREADY UP PROVIDES --
NOW CATIA ERA DIRECTION OF
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
FOR HYDROGEN.
ó THAT'S FEES IN PLACE THAT
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE IT WAS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE PREPARATION
THAT.
THE MEMBER THE PUBLIC REFERENCE
TO MERELY --
REPEATS AND DUPLICATES
MEMORIALIZES WHAT WAS ALREADY IN
THE STATUTE.
OF THE BUDGET BILL THAT YOU'RE
LOOKING AT NOW JUST --
HAS A ONE TOTAL AMOUNT BUT I I
WOULD SAY THAT IT'S CERTAINLY
THE THE INTENT IN THE
EXPECTATION THAT.
THE EXISTING --
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS THAT
CURRENTLY IN STATUE IN THAT
WON'T CHANGE WILL WILL REMAIN.
THANK YOU ENOUGH FOLLOW UP
QUESTION NOT ON THE SAME TOPIC.
THE GOVERNOR HAS A GOAL OF FIVE
CREATING TWO HUNDRED DATA.
HYDROGEN FUELING STATIONS I
THINK WHERE THIRTY SOMETHING
RIGHT NOW AND I'M WONDERING IF
YOU CAN --
AT THAT.
I JUST INFORM US HOW A A WITH
THE ROADMAP AS FORWARD FOR
BUILDING OUT THOSE TWO HUNDRED
STATIONS AND A WHERE WE GET THIS
YEAR WITH OUR ALLOCATIONS.
I THINK YOU WE ORIGINALLY HAD
PART -- KIND
OF ON A PARALLEL TRACK WITH OUR
CAP AND TRADE PROPOSAL A AS THEY
HAVE PROPOSAL WHICH INCLUDED
INFRASTRUCTURE I'M FORCING WE
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO REACH
AGREEMENT ON NOT PARTICULAR
PORTION WE DO LOOK FOR TO
ONGOING CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON TO GET TO THAT
POINT.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS COMMITTED
TO ENSURING THAT THERE'S ENOUGH
INFRASTRUCTURE TO MEET THE GOAL --
CARS ARE ONE PART BUT
INFRASTRUCTURES A VERY IMPORTANT
PART OF MEETING THAT GOAL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU --
WE ATTEMPT TO PUBLIC COMMENT FOR
THAT BY QUESTIONS SO GOING BACK
TO PUBLIC COMMENT ANY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC IN OPPOSITION TO SB.
EIGHT FIVE SIX OKAY OR SEEN DONE.
THEN -- ANY
LAST COMMENTS QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
GREAT THEN BEFORE WE ADJOURN
JUST ONE OF ANNOUNCED THAT HE BE
S. B. EIGHT FIVE SEVEN GOING TO
BE AMENDED SO WE WILL HEAR IT
ALONG WITH S. B..
EIGHT SEVEN TWO ON THURSDAY
MORNING WE ANTICIPATE HAVING A
HEARING AT EIGHT THIRTY ON
THURSDAY MORNING.
AND WITH THAT THE COMMITTEE IS
ADJOURNED THANK YOU